acusado de minimizar la amenaza del
cubil 19 donald trump está ahora a la
defensiva el presidente de eeuu intentó
el jueves poner fin a la controversia
surgida tras la revelación de audios de
entrevistas concedidas al periodista bob
woodward quiero mostrar un nivel de
confianza quiero mostrar fortaleza como
líder y quiero mostrar que nuestro país
va a estar bien de una manera u otra ya
sea que perdamos a una persona no
deberíamos haber perdido a nadie porque
esto no debió haber ocurrido esto es
culpa de china no es culpa de nadie más
sino de china chinas no debió haber
permitido que esto ocurriera
según las grabaciones publicadas por el
periódico washington post de entrevistas
realizadas en febrero por el periodista
bob woodward trump reconoció que sabía
lo peligroso que era el coronavirus
siempre quise minimizarlo todavía me
gusta minimizarlo porque no quiero crear
pánico
el hecho ha dado a sus opositores
demócratas una nueva oportunidad para
atacar we can say your heart tiempos así
que continuamos teniendo ejemplos del
hecho de que este es un individuo que no
se preocupa por la salud y la seguridad
y el bienestar del pueblo americano en
google vende mercancía
y francamente está comprometido con mi
desprecio imprudente por las vidas la
salud y el bienestar de la gente de
nuestro país es algo escandaloso
rivard cancer pain desaguar rangers las
encuestas siguen poniendo a bailén muy
por encima de chiang el mandatario ha
tratado de cambiar la retórica
enfocándose en un discurso de ley orden
sin embargo su manejo de la pandemia que
ya ha cobrado más de 190.000 vidas en el
país vuelve a la primera plana pero a
pesar de las críticas volvió a reunir a
sus seguidores en michigan sin
mascarilla su distanciamiento